[Applause]
and time
happy weekend everybody there's new
infinity war that just dropped a new
thor ragnarok so i figured to be a good
opportunity to talk about Thor vs. Hulk
in Ragnarok and in the comics like who's
more powerful and than them both getting
promptly smashed by Thanos and then the
Avengers for stuff that's happening so
we'll start with Ragnarok then I'll move
into infinity war stuff at the end of
the video because in Ragnarok they're
relatively evenly matched but there are
a couple other versions in the comics
like necro sword Thor or rune King Thor
and world breaker Hulk or the version of
Hulk that was the Herald of Galactus so
we could debate on who could beat who
because I have a few theories about the
way the movies gonna treat this but
because the movie isn't gonna be coming
out till November it's a little early to
start doing movie ticket stuff so I'll
say like the Marvel giveaway still for
an epaulette subscription because
defenders dropped and I still think a
lot of people haven't seen all of it yet
so all you have to do to enter that is
just be a subscriber leave a comment
about Ragnarok but when you're talking
about who would win in a fight between
Thor and Hulk the movie footage that
we've seen so far in the trailers makes
it look like Hulk pounce him pretty
easily and then they had that funny
moment where Thor tells Banner who
doesn't remember oh I totally won easily
in banner being really nice just kind of
looks off into the distance and thinks
oh you know that doesn't sound bright
because I'm supposed to be the most
powerful person but in reality it just
depends on which version you're talking
about
and what sort of limitations you put on
the characters so in the context of the
movie you have a hammerless Thor against
a normal version of hawk we assume that
there's not any big limitations on him
like he's wielding weapons he's wearing
his gladiator armor from Planet Hulk
but unlike Planet Hook it doesn't look
like he has any of the control cylinders
attached to him so in the comics all the
gladiators have little control cylinders
that limit their powers that keep them
from escaping it'll be interesting to
see how the movie deals with that
because this seems like a relatively
normal version of Hulk who's just been
here for a while and just really
enjoying smashing everybody in the arena
but sort of working our way up the tiers
just as they present it here hammerless
thor versa normal hulk wouldn't have a
chance Hulk would smash him so there's
probably some funny way that they end
this fight because I don't think they
want to make Thor look like too much of
a [ __ ] but it
or did have his hammer then yeah he
could totally take the Hulk at least
fight him to a stalemate like you saw
during the first Avengers film he had
all those funny moments with hope trying
to pick the hammer up getting all
distracted it wouldn't stick for long
but the whole idea is that Thor wouldn't
be able to defeat Hulk he'd just be able
to hold him until they could get him
inside that containment unit and that
would hold him for at least a little
while but if Thor can pound his way out
of that with the hammer then Houk
probably would have been able to pound
his way out too but you can kind of see
how they want to make the MCU versions
of the characters seem relatively equal
it just depends on who's doing what to
who and how dirty they're fighting but
what about the crazy Opie versions of
the characters so there's really like
two most powerful versions of Thor in
the comics like I said there's necrose
or Thor who's a version of Thor who has
absorbed Gore's necro sword from the god
butcher storyline but then there's also
the rune King Thor who's supposed to be
like a little bit more powerful than
that but he only had the power of the
rune King for a very brief period while
he was defeating all of Earth's heroes
including the Hulk on the other side of
that you have world breaker Hulk which
is this a version of Hulk who's gotten
more mad than he's ever gotten before in
the comics his strength is measured as a
function of his anger so theoretically
he has limitless strength but it's not
really infinite and then there's the
even more powerful version of Hulk that
became the Herald of Galactus wielding
cosmic power like Silver Surfer so like
who would win rune King Thor or Herald
of Galactus Hulk because they're both
wielding a level of cosmic power that
version of the fight would probably wind
up being the same outcome as this
version in the movie it would probably
be a stalemate because even though rune
King Thor is wielding the odinforce in
addition to the powers of the rune King
he has like just crazy cosmic powers
layered on top of other crazy cosmic
powers he can manipulate dimensions he
has molecular manipulation like Galactus
has which he then gives to his heralds
so Herald of Galactus Hulk would have a
lot of the same powers as rune King Thor
and it would really just get down to the
idea of who could use their powers the
best because just because you give
someone a lot of power doesn't mean they
know how to use it immediately but on a
concept level rune King Thor was just
meant to be the most powerful version of
the character that they've ever done in
the comics like so crazy Opie that he
defeated all of Earth's heroes in the
way that world breaker Hulk did but with
a bunch of extra cosmic powers on top of
that so I'm not ever expecting them to
do that in the comics this version of
Thor that we've been saying in the
trailers is not ruin King Thor I think
he just absorbed the power of the hammer
so like he's literally become the
Thunder God they call him the Thunder
God but there's always the question of
whether or not he can summon the storm
without the hammer the whole idea of the
movie is that he just gets his big
upgrade so when you seem during infinity
war he is prepped for Thanos level
threat
[Music]
but I know you're all still wondering
about when they're gonna drop that
official trailer they've started filming
the second infinity war film now it's
not called infinity war it's just gonna
be called Avengers something else I know
we've had a secret invasion theory but
Thanos is coming back so it'll be closer
to the actual Infinity Gauntlet
storyline like we've talked about how
the first infinity war film seems more
like fan o's quest from the comics the
story of him collecting the gems the
fourth Avengers film seems more like
what he does once he actually does
assemble the gauntlet however close
they're gonna stick to the comics I have
already done a version of that infinity
war trailer they'll probably release
another longer version in the next month
or two most of their times gonna be
spent promoting Ragnarok once we get
closer to that that's when you'll start
seeing official infinity war stuff so
I'm not expecting that till October but
Black Panther is coming out before
infinity war so you're gonna see a whole
lot of that dropping around Ragnarok too
so there's gonna be a whole bunch of
really big Marvel stuff happening
because next year is also the 10th
anniversary of Marvel Studios so a lot
of the infinity war stuff is meant to
tie in with that so if Thanos and the
Infinity Gauntlet wasn't big enough for
you they're gonna be doing all kinds of
extra stuff on top of that but what will
happen is is because the Game of Thrones
finale is this weekend obviously
tomorrow is gonna be all kinds of stuff
I have some new Rick and Morty to post
but leave all your requests for Marvel
stuff in the comments below there'll be
a lot more big Marvel stuff happening
pretty soon but I'll name the giveaway
winner the next time I post a Marvel
video so while you wait for that click
here for that infinity war trailer video
and you can click here to get ready for
the Game of Thrones finale thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight